how do you handle security in a multi
cloud world many companies today are
moving some or all of their application
topologies to the public cloud which
leaves them with a multi cloud
environment that they need to manage and
this introduces a number of risks when
it comes to handling challenges around
security and compliance let's take a
look at an example of a fictitious
company a bank called demo bank and how
they handle this journey to multi cloud
while maintaining the security and
compliance they needed to keep their
customers data safe so let's start at
the beginning
demo Bank has a mobile application that
allows their clients to check their
balances and transfer money between
accounts and do all the things that most
people can do on mobile banking
applications their customers are
reasonably happy and they're providing
industry standard capabilities for a
mobile application their IT operations
team is pretty happy as well because
since all of their components are
running inside their data center they're
easily able to monitor the security and
compliance of the entire architecture
but demo bank wants to modernize they
want to give themselves the ability to
take advantage in the future of public
cloud services and add new capabilities
to their application so the first thing
they do is they move their application
to micro services and what micro
services does it allows them to
decompose their application into smaller
components which gives advantages
because they can be developed quicker
and an independent of each other and
they can also be portable and move
potentially to a public cloud should the
company wish to do that so once they've
gone through this transformation their
customers aren't about the same spot as
they were before the application is
exactly as it was before IT ops is happy
they still have a security and
compliance view that covers the entire
data center all the components are
inside the data center but demo Bank
isn't done their modernization journey
takes them to adding a new micro service
a virtual assistant this virtual
assistant will connect
to services in the public cloud in the
public cloud they'll take advantage of
artificial intelligence services whether
services and traffic services to provide
their clients with the closest ATM to
them and updates on whether that
impending snowstorm is going to close
their branch office in the next couple
days this of course makes their
end-users very happy it makes their
developers very happy because they get
to take advantage of new cloud services
and build them into their application
ops on the other hand has some concerns
by opening up this connection to public
cloud services we've now exposed
potential risk to secure client data in
the system of record out to public cloud
services this can expose demo bank to
things that could tarnish their brand it
could cause them to lose customers and
lose shareholder value so what's the
solution they need to bring in a single
central control plane that allows them
to put compliance policies across all of
their application components both
on-premise and in the cloud that lets IT
ops tick the Box be happy that they have
security and compliance in the same way
that they did when they were managing
the application on-premise so at the end
of the day when you add a multi cloud
environment plus a control plane for
governance and security your developers
get to have their cake and your CEO gets
to eat it too when it comes to new
clients and not ending up on the front
page of The Wall Street Journal for
losing a customer data
thank you for watching this video to
learn more check out the next video in
the series where you can learn how the
IBM cloud pack for multi cloud
management can help you with all of your
multi cloud governance risk and security
needs